[Music]
either Disney moved to another residence
or they stole someone else's castle lets
us tell an old story in you that's all
you guys do nowadays also basically they
saw wicked and said let's do that with
one of our evil female characters there
were two kingdoms also narration Moors
land is a discount pandora movie rips
off the rocks look like faces thing from
a bunch of movies but the first that
comes to mind is King Kong
three-position and her name was
Maleficent roll credits also Maleficent
that sounds like a cross between
malfeasance and magnificent you know who
demonstrated magnificent malfeasance the
parents of this girl who gave her such
an obvious evil villain named and then
promptly died well it's the same camp
I've been wearing for years and years
thanks for noticing just now none of
this needs to make any sense or even
matter so long as you were filled with a
sense of wonder I take umbrage of the
casting of this fairy you mean to tell
me these tree guards can't walk up to
this kids hiding place and arrest him
I've been standing here for god knows
how long just waiting to Wow what are
the odds
seems like something you should have
noticed before you shook his hand
but hey great way to explain your one
weakness so that we know how to kill you
later you could have just put it in your
pocket right
what risk what do you do for fun how
often do you get a chance to do this for
fun ever
how many hanging buddies do you have in
this world fairy second base he told her
it was true love's kiss but it was
actually herpes flying through a
dangerous natural obstacle course cliche
the mysterious Moors where no one dares
to venture this is something I surely
said even before we started this journey
but sometimes my men need a good
reminding of why they're here
even if the trip only took an hour tops
so the treat army saves the day geez
lord of the rings' punch tree dragon no
fairies were harmed in the making of
this scene because well she used a tree
army and presumably all the fairies are
back at home chilling and playing call
of duty
she couldn't yell at the King from a
safer distance also when you flew
through the battle knocking all these
soldiers down how did you miss touching
iron that whole time held during this
scene alone you should have been burned
about four or five times and all was as
it happened long ago whatever that was
this relationship is whatever the
narrator tells us it is I know when I
poison my girlfriend's I throw the
capsule nearby so that people can see it
later there's no one in the tree army
pay attention to the stuff going on
among the trees like their leader being
attacked
[Music]
conscience oh no a thing it's just like
that nightmare scenario when I woke up
in Mexico and my liver was gone she did
research for the scene by consulting
jennifer aniston on what it feels like
to get your wink lit by someone you know
he's still here also if you were willing
to do this why not just kill her I mean
this is far worse than killing her and
you know it
I have avenged you SIA she's that
question but of course she is your whole
army couldn't kill her a minute ago but
not at all spectacular errand boy Stefan
went into the woods and killed her all
by himself of course we interrupt this
Disney fairy tale retelling to bring you
the necromancers castle from The Hobbit
what a dick
wait did she know that the bird would
fly over here and get caught the net um
how come her own powerful dark magic
can't just create her a new pair of
wings what have you done to my beautiful
self man for a bird you're an awfully
vain aren't you
I didn't return to save my life I am
your servant couldn't she just have
asked a bird to help her
King thickest doesn't have brown arms in
this coronation humans helpfully leave a
window open so Maleficent's new bird
soldier can eavesdrop and then the bird
spy hears one sentence introducing King
Stefan and flies away as though no other
pertinent information could possibly be
gleaned from this event it's a good
thing this day advanced so quickly and
tonight so that the king could witness
the spectacle of the green energy going
into the sky also how does someone with
magic this powerful need a whole movie
to win King Stefan and the Queen have
had a child she waited nine months just
to see if a plan revealed itself to her
what has she been doing this whole time
why do these fairies never age and
Maleficent whom we have also been told
as a fairy grows like a human child hey
the lights went out and there's a scary
wind and stuff at the Kings baby's
christening let's all part like the Red
Sea and allow the creepy new person it
just won't so right up to him did she
put a wrapping around her horns but why
want to understand maleficents powers
and how and when and why they work and
why there's any conflict in this movie
at all well cute before the Sun sets on
her 16th birthday
damn that's like sixteen freaking years
why not make the curse happen before her
eighth birthday and split the difference
she will
what an oddly specific revenge plot why
not a fishing hook or the tip of a spear
why is your greatest revenge to make the
guy that pissed you off
daughter fall asleep but not actually
dock how does this even make you feel a
little bit better I could just do it now
but 16 is good enough what do you think
I am some kind of monster the princess
can be woken from her death sleep but
only by true love's kiss Jesus and then
she left King Stefan didn't bother to
call his army or have someone threw a
bucket of iron honor who would take her
to a remote hideaway for 16 years why
burn the spindles when you were gonna
take her to a remote place anyway now
everyone has to sew by hand you dick
while his soldiers rode far and wide to
hunt Maleficent down they had a prime
chance to do that when she was here
earlier but they were probably scared by
her powers but now though I bet all
that's changed since then why did they
waste all that time Stephane knows
exactly where maleficent's kingdom is
right oh sweet
they don't do you special effects for a
while no questions asked raising our
orphan child would because that's common
enough for there to be no questions the
crow servant finds the baby and
faeries literally 60 seconds after they
start hiding and only because the
faeries are so stupid they go inside
without the baby
haha these faeries are negligent but as
this baby lived long enough and
interacted with these Pixies long enough
to always be hiding open window is handy
for a Maleficent to walk straight up and
see the conveniently placed window baby
these stupid fairies agreed to take care
of a kid for 16 years without any
warning to king stefan's that they
didn't know about babies crow sign
it's going to stop at this relooking
authoress one day in and maleficent
already feels empathy for the creature
she's trying to cause to suffer
still can't grow your wings though huh
keep trying you've tried right you can
also call that amazing tree dragon and
go beat these dudes up I imagine we'll
never see that tree dragon again for
some reason oh yeah the one weakness
I've known about since I was 12
bring me the ironworkers um all of them
I'm sure you don't just want to see one
of them maybe like the head iron worker
maleficent spends her time messing with
the three fairies who used to be her
loyal friends fYI for no reason other
than the movie needs some filler and
obviously Maleficent ain't got to do so
I'm still trying to figure out why
Stefan and trusted these dumb fairies
with caring for his daughter after
meeting them for five seconds that one
day haha ya know there's no way these
stupid-ass fairies didn't already kill
this kid with stupid she's dead man
we've seen the original horns the horns
wrapped in black leather and now the
horns and shiny dragon scales this woman
is dedicated to horn fashion I guess
it's a good thing she didn't jump off
the part of that cliff that didn't have
branches it's not a Disney movie if some
pure chick isn't making friendly with
the local wildlife do the fairies pay
any attention to where this girl is how
far from the cottage in the woods is the
thorn wall cuz I'm thinking it's pretty
far hanging out does she really need him
to bring them to her can't she just do
whatever she needs to do right now Magic
Man how does it work yeah what would
Maleficent ever have done without the
wolf behind these guys are you thinking
she could just do the same thing without
him I'm thinking she could have just
done the same thing without so she can
lift other people off the ground into
the air and control where they go using
her magic but she still needs wings if
she wants to fly herself this movie
gives fewer folks about you
understanding its magic than the Harry
Potter films exactly 48 percent of the
lines Angelina Jolie says in this movie
are hmm the subtitles on this movie just
told me that these are fairies too if
they're female and fly around they're
fairies
end of story whoever I went your shadow
is always with me what I know the movies
trying to find a way to say she had a
feeling someone was watching her but
this is a lousy ass explanation even for
this movie discount Schindler's List
music
[Music]
absolutely none of Aurora's caretakers
are freaking out worried about her
absence when the touch feels Maleficent
will comfort me that's another thing
what the hell is a curse that can be so
easily avoided even though Stephane
decided to use that throw the baby out
with the bathwater method
maleficents kurz is one of the least
thought out in the history of curses and
Stefan's response to what is one of the
least thought out in the history of
responses I guess those other fairies
are finally dead
what happened to them who knows probably
jumped off a cliff trying to save Aurora
I guess well I guess the last sixteen
years of waiting and messing with
fairies by making their hands fall off
was all worth it that right you already
said that I heard you the first two
times Oh see that's all I wish to say
about it what color were they Jesus they
never faltered just them your wings they
were part of your body right like
imagine saying this about your hands or
fingers
it sounds pretty stupid right true love
decoy man it's a wonder this chick
didn't die of some random forest thing
all the time she spends unsupervised
true love's kiss remember I can break
the spell and for some reason no one
understands that the spell doesn't even
have to be a thing ever
as long as spindles stay out of her
world we're already worried that the
handsome traveler guy might be her only
hope and she hasn't even touched a
spinning wheel yet said it was an evil
fairy I can't remember her name Oh
nonsense
if they said it you remember her name
give me a break
why are you this far behind trying to
find Aurora the girl even went to the
Moors to see if the whole cursed thing
was true but you're so far behind
Aurora's already locked up in a room at
the castle why is she checking out her
finger oh yeah that's a finger right for
the fricking right they're looking for a
girl already how long has it been since
you were lost and looking for the castle
like one hour that's cheating
she finds the one undestroyed spinning
wheel which is only reconstructed by
magic okay whatever but my main concern
is how have they been making linens and
clothes for the last 16 years
also if the curse basically beckons you
to prick your finger on a spinning wheel
what's the general point why not just
make it so that she falls asleep on her
16th birthday and call it a day if it's
inevitable then why go through the
trouble of making the curse so specific
oh wait stop don't go into the spindle
dungeon you might prick yourself I've
did everything I could to prevent this
help if we go inside those walls we'll
never come out alive except for the last
time she did with all that magic and
stuff right right wait last time we saw
them they were entering the castle now
they're at some kind of iron thorn maze
the oh that's in the castle you
movie aha yes using magic as a
distraction is great but forgetting that
you can use magic on the guard without a
distraction is pretty damn lame what a
surprise that kiss didn't work
now let's immediately head for frozen
territory so that when Maleficent kisses
her it will work because what a twist
we've never seen before the power of
kissing takes a super long time to work
for dramatic purposes cliche true enough
no true love then the love of an evil
fairy who cursed a girl to eternal
slumber but then accidentally gain
feelings for through spending time
together you're absolutely right
do they have metal net setup in every
room in this castle or just this one
because that's a super lucky guess if
that's the case but I can't do anything
about this net I don't even have the
power to make it fly off me for some
reason I don't know how these soldiers
aren't getting completely burned by the
dragon's fire but hey maybe we can't ask
for more from a thing that used to be a
burger just a minute ago I guess I'm
just gonna have to accept this
Maleficent let's gravity decide this and
she invited Aurora to see how the laws
had been once wasn't it's still pretty
awesome in the Moors hello she got that
pit this thing and nothing looked
particularly awful now you're saying the
Moors handle this over growth and
general awfulness the whole time
Maleficent was sort of evil ha I was the
one they called Sleeping Beauty roll
credit oh wait
oh I thought this was about to play the
Harry Potter theme music for a second
movie literally has nine minutes of
closing credits it's moose
[Music]
what's all the fuss about things at
Hogwarts a far worse than I feared
it's extremely rude don't listen to him
Balthazar you're classically handsome
I'm called Stefan new New York's hottest
club is wimzie
what's wrong
your ring iron burns fairies
[Music]
rice varieties by the defendant spell
shall be shaken shields shall be
splintered
[Music]
listen well all of you cook I'm woody
howdy howdy howdy hmm I'm sorry that we
crashed the vehicle and ruin someone's
room Sleeping Beauty
[Music]